- [Voiceover] Let's look at the clock
and see what time is shown.
The clock has two hands;
this first shorter one,
which represents the hours,
and then there's a longer hand here
that represents the minutes.
So, we can start with the hours,
this shorter hand right here.
Before we can figure out the hours,
you may have noticed our
clock is not labeled.
So let's add some labels.
At the top of the clock,
here, is always 12 o'clock.
That's where the hour hand starts
and, then, the hour hand really only deals
with these larger square marks.
So when it works its
way to this first one,
then it is now 1 o'clock.
And when it gets to the
next one, 2 o'clock,
and three and four, five and so on,
until we work our way all
the way back to 12 o'clock.
So now our hour hand,
let's look at our hour hand right here.
We can see it's just barely past the 10,
but it hasn't reached 11.
So that means our hour,
it's after 10 o'clock,
maybe 10:05, maybe 10:30,
but it hasn't reached 11 yet,
so we can safely put
a 10 in for our hours.
Now let's switch to minutes.
Here's our minute hand, and it looks like
it's lined up to this little mark.
Minutes are shorter and they also use
these shorter marks on the clock.
The minute hand starts facing up,
so when the minute hand
was here it was 10 o'clock
and then it moved one minute,
so it was one minute after 10 or 10:01.
10:02, 10:03, 10:04, 10:05.
So, this is five minutes
after 10, and it keeps going.
10:06, 10:07, 10:08, 10:09,
10:10 right here,
and maybe you can see this
pattern, it keeps going.
Here it was zero minutes after the hour.
So it was zero, then five, then 10.
So this one is gonna be 15.
We're gonna keep counting by fives.
And then one more minute after that is 16.
So it is 10:16 or 16 minutes after 10.
One more here.
Let's again start with our hour hand.
And we know our labels; we
know this is 12, one, two.
We could keep labeling, but our hour hand
is facing right there so
we really don't need to.
The hour hand is between one and two.
So it's after one, but not yet two.
So it's one something,
and by looking at our minutes we can see
it's quite a bit after one.
This minute hand has
worked its way around.
And remember this is gonna
be five minutes after,
10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40.
We can't go to 45, that's too far.
So let's go back to 40 and
now just count by ones.
41, 42, 43, 44.
Our minute hand lines up here to
44 minutes after 1 o'clock or 1:44.